[Musique]
au revoir notre président donc on va
bien voir un petit peu les perspectives
de ce qui vient c'est de pouvoir avoir
un petit peu président nous voilà déjà
c'est la première fois depuis je
travaille au conseil général afin que ce
président fait présente ses voeux
c'est énorme c'est plein d'optimisme que
près de 400 agents du département se
sont réunis pour les voeux du président
du département et de son équipe
[Musique]
je crois que les services du département
monsieur le président vous le dirai
mieux que moi on était présent pour
répondre aux exigences de la gouvernance
politique répondre aux exigences et aux
demandes de nos administrés donc je
voudrais vous dire en qualité de
directeur général des services mais
aussi au nom de l'équipe de direction
tous mes remerciements et toute ma
reconnaissance pour l'action de vous et
que vous avez entreprises une séance de
rattrapage apprécié notamment par les
agents des routes de permanence lors du
dernier cycle guitare nous avons la
chance d'avoir des agents qui savent
s'impliquer quand il ya des coups durs
vous avez est mobilisé pour justement
venir en aide aux familles de la région
et vous avez su répondre présent alors
aujourd'hui je vous dis merci pour votre
engagement et vous pouvez si vous fait
vous applaudir territoire a été vraiment
pris pendant cette période surtout sur
un première semaine après big heat a en
a débloqué les hiboux aigles et tous les
bouts il fallait tout nettoyer les
caniveaux et c'est de voir les problèmes
que les riverains ont rencontré aussi
dus aux inondations
voilà c'est tout c'est tout le travail
l'organisation des équipes travaillent
avec des entreprises privées ont là
c'était c'était il y avait vraiment une
grande relation s'était faite et humain
dès la prise de parole cyrille melchior
impulser les valeurs et donne quelques
orientations pour l'année 2018 il n'est
pas question de remettre en cause malgré
tous nos politiques publiques
volontaristes notamment je le dis dans
le domaine social pour moi c'est un
moment d'échangé de dialogue avec les
agents du conseil départemental
je les apprécie beaucoup parce que je
sais que chacun a sa place à son niveau
dans son service travaille pour la
collectivité travaille pour les familles
réunionnaises avec 5400 cathage en ces
moments des changes avec le comité
exécutif sont une réelle opportunité un
moment également pour partager entre les
agents car cette démarche ne peut être
que collective
nous sommes à une période
l'histoire de la réunion nous avons des
difficultés on le voit bien
et si on ne sait pas fédérer les
énergies tirer vers le haut ce que nous
avons en nous quoi justement essayer de
leur apporter des solutions aux
problèmes bord n'y arrivera pas une
rencontre qui se termine autour d'un
déjeuner plein d'humour de quoi
souhaiter le meilleur pour cette
nouvelle année ensemble allons bâtir le
conseil départemental de demain ensemble
allons rester au service de la
population réunionnaise qui en a tant
besoin
[Musique]